- [Kelly] Well, I saw this video
it's the whole cast and it went viral.
So I wanna show everybody this.
So, what was going on here?
This was impromptu, look at Sterling!
(audience laughs)
- This was like us on a break.
So we had like all this time,
this was like a 18-hour day.
And we were there from six o'clock,
look at the booties
- Look at the booties.
- We were there from
like, I think I got there
at eight o'clock in the morning.
I remember leaving just
after midnight, but
we were all there and we were shooting
Kate's second wedding to Phil and
a wonderful person who runs our social
Sarah Warehime came in, she
always has ideas for us to do.
And she was coming to
Sterling with something.
And I think between her
and Sterling, they came up
with this idea and he was
asking me about music choices.
And I was like, oh, you should
do something that people
would play at a barbecue.
Everybody can dance.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he came up with the wobble
and then he taught everybody.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know, I was
- Except for Mr. Hartley.
He's just chilling on
the couch on the phone
- See, he knows his position.
He's knows. He's like
"I know my lane, I'ma be here."
- [Kelly] Does he not dance?
Is this what it is?
- No ma'am. He just
- No, ma'am good.
- And listen, does he not do it well?
Did he not do that well?
- He did it well, I love it
he is just on the phone, like
He's making deals while
everyone's dancing, I love it.
I was like, "that just
means he don't dance"
And that's what we do on our break.
That was like a break.
And, and we were, you
know, it's the way to like
just kinda get through the day.